Musik Ich sage Podcast, du sagst UFO, Podcast, Ufo, Podcast, Uütze hat ja Pläne, hat ja nicht so wahnsinnig viel Zeit.
Ich fliege nach Dublin gleich, einen Kumpel besuchen, der ein Auslandssemester macht. Ich habe nicht so viel Zeit, das zu erklären, weil wir haben heute nicht viel Zeit.
Schnell, schnell, schnell, schnell, schnell! Und ich bin gedanklich gar nicht beim Pottglas, ich bin gedanklich voll bei meinem Koffer, den habe ich gerade angefangen zu packen und ich weiß nicht genau, habe ich alles, ich denke die ganze Zeit, hat das alles zu vergessen, wo, wo ist der Haken, wo ist der Haken und ich fliege zum ersten Mal ohne Koffer, sondern nur mit Handgepäck und ich weiß nicht genau, wie das funktioniert und weiß nicht genau, wie viel ich mitnehmen kann und deswegen habe ich so ein paar Probleme und bin gedanklich nicht auf der Höhe, das war es von mir und Florentin übernimmt. Ich übernehme, wir haben heute das Thema Scham tatsächlich, denn wir schämen uns auch ein bisschen für diese kleine Folge. Wollen wir nicht vielleicht über Dinge reden, über Reisen reden und was man vielleicht vergessen haben könnte? Man hat mich jetzt komplett auf das Thema Scham vorbereitet, aber Reisen ist ja auch eine schamvolle Sache.
Man schämt sich ja, manche Dinge sind zu groß, manche Dinge sind zu klein, zu kurz, zu lang, unser Podcast ist viel zu kurz, ansonsten zu lang, man ist nie wirklich drin, Stefan ist zu groß, man ist irgendwie immer nicht ganz so, wie man möchte, man schämt sich für viele verschiedene Dinge. Viele Ängste, die man heutzutage hat, beziehen sich ja darauf, dass man sich schämen könnte in naher Zukunft.
Zum Beispiel, ich habe gerade Angst davor, dass mein Koffer zu gross ist.
Und da ich ja kein Gepäck habe und es nicht zur Gepäckabgabe gibt, wo es ja nachgemessen wird und sowas und gewogen wird, gehe ich ja direkt in die Sicherheitskontrolle. Und das ist total peinlich, wenn man da nämlich einen Fehler begeht, dann alle hinter dir rollen erst mal mit den Augen und drehen sich so zu ihrem Hintermann um und schütteln mit dem Kopf so, das kann doch nicht sein, was ist das einer? Und dann habe ich halt auch, schäme ich mich dann. Das ist tatsächlich auch ein Hauptgrund, warum ich nicht fliege, sondern eher Zugfahre, weil da redet hier niemand rein, da kannst du so viel mitnehmen, wie du willst. Ich bin mir generell mit einem aufblasbaren Krokodil unterwegs und da gibt es natürlich im Flughafen immer Probleme. Also du würdest dich dann für deine Inkompetenz schämen, dass du sowas nicht im Vorhinein weist, dass du sowas eigentlich wissen musst. Ja genau, du musst auch beim Fliegen für das Krokodil einen eigenen Sitzplatz machen. Ja genau, oder zum Beispiel wenn man ein Bügelbrett kauft und man ist schon in einem gewissen Alter und jeder, der dich mit diesem Bügelbrett in der U-Bahn sieht, denkt, aha, wir haben bis jetzt noch kein Bügelbrett gebraucht, aber was mein Lieber, du bist 28 Jahre alt und hast noch nie was gebügelt, was hast du für ein Leben geführt, du Versager. Vor allem neulich bin ich U-Bahn gefahren und da hatte jemand ein Skelett mit. Das war ein Skelett in der U-Bahn gefahren.
Das ist auch sehr eingefallen. Das Skelett hat sich ein bisschen nackt gefühlt in der Situation. Es ist halt immer eine verschiedene Schamhafte Situation. Ja, so ist es. Aber mein Tipp, um einfach diesen Gag, der wüsste unterbrochen wurde, falls ihr mal ein Bügelbrett kauft, zieht euch einfach irgendwie coole Shorts an, eine Sonnenbrille und tut einfach so, als werdet ihr auf dem Weg zum Strand und singt irgendwie Beach Boys. Von daher überhaupt kein Problem. Charme abgewendet.
Zum Thema Charme.
Beach Boys sind auch eine super Band.
Ganz kurz, nur als Einwand.
Ich habe mir letztens tatsächlich ein paar unserer Podcasts angehört,
ein bisschen reingehört.
Und da kommt natürlich auch an vielen Stellen viel Charme hoch.
Aber mir ist aufgefallen,
wir hatten früher viel häufiger über Sprichwörter geredet.
Und deswegen möchte ich jetzt auch gleich ein bisschen mit dem Sprichwort anfangen.
Weil es ist ja schon verrückt, wo diese Sprichwörter herkommen.
Also vor allem, was passiert, wenn man die das erste Mal benutzt.
Mir ist es ein Wetter, der sich in den Wetterter herkommen. Also vor allem, was passiert, wenn man die das erste Mal benutzt? Und mir ist zum Beispiel ein Sprichwort in den Sinn gekommen, einem Geschenkengaul schaut man nicht ins Maul. Hat dieses Sprichwort nicht eine gewisse Ironie, wenn man sich die Geschichte von Troja anschaut? Ich meine, ist das nicht ein Schlag ins Gesicht der Trojaner, wenn man das so übernimmt? Ich meine, da hätte man eine ganze Stadt retten können. Bis dahin war das das Sprichwort perfekt. Ja, genau. Bis dahin war es perfekt. Und als ob die Spartaner das damals Nein, Griechen nicht. War es einen Moment, ganz kurz. Griechen, Griechen gegen Troja. Ich bin jetzt, wo war ich jetzt? Red einfach weiter. Wo war ich jetzt? Spartaner anscheinend. Die Griechen haben dann damals Troja angegriffen und... Sehr gut. Ich wollte es ja so sagen, damit man es schneiden kann. Sie sind die Geschichtsabfrage, erstmal mit trivialen Dingen anfangen und sich dann langsam hocharbeiten. Und dann sind die Griechen gekommen, als ob sie nur dieses Sprichwort kaputt machen wollen. Warum gerade ein Pferd? Einfach Pferd und ein Sprichwort. Ja genau, die hatten irgendwann angegriffen wegen Helena irgendwie, weil die so schön ist und nach acht Jahren hat die das eh wieder vergessen. Irgendwann war das völlig egal, einfach nur wegen dem Sprichwort. Aber meinst du nicht, dass das Sprichwort irgendwas mit Troja zu tun hat? Weil es ist schon ein Zufall, ne? Geschenkter Gaul, da denkt jeder sofort an Troja, aber dann die ironische Wendung sozusagen schaut nicht in den Maul. Vielleicht ist es auch ein missverstandener Gag einfach, der irgendwann zu so einem ernst genommenen Sprichwort wurde, aber eigentlich missverstanden ist die ganze Zeit. Oder genau dieses Sprichwort war schuld daran, dass Troja eingenommen wurde, weil man hat dieses Pferd bekommen und gesagt, sollen wir dem mal ins Maul schauen? Und dann hat sie gesagt, nee, nee, pass mal auf, einem geschenkten Gaul schaut man nicht ins Maul. Das war übrigens das erste Mal, dass dieses Sprichwort benutzt wurde. Es war einfach ein riesen satirischer Scoop von den Griechen damals, um der Welt zu zeigen, dass man nicht auf Sprichwörter vertrauen sollte vielleicht.
Das waren die ersten Satiriker, kann man so sagen.
Aber es geriet in Vergessenheit und das ist auch so meine Angst.
Ich schäme mich dafür, dass man vielleicht in ein paar Jahren überhaupt nicht mehr über das Podcast UFO redet. Und dieser ganze Ruhm, den wir aufgebaut haben, verfliegt wie ein Laubhaufen im Frühlingswind. Und das ist einfach, da habe ich keine Lust drauf. Deswegen möchte ich auch mit dieser Folge, mit dieser Speed-Folge, mit der, ich nenne sie mal die Folge für Unentschlossene, die nicht ganz wissen, macht mir der Podcast Spaß, habe ich da Lust drauf, sind mir die Typen sympathisch, die einfach mal reinhören können und mal gucken, ob das was für sie ist. Denn, ja, mach nur, einatmen ist schon Gesprächsbeteiligung, da bin ich ganz knallhart. Das ist mein neuer Trick, ich atme sehr laut ein, damit du merkst, dass ich was sagen will. Das hat ja auch funktioniert offensichtlich. Apropos Scham, du, gestern war ja der 1. April, ne, und 1. April fand ich früher als Kind total geil, ich dachte mir immer, super, cool, alle machen Scherze, alle sind für einen kleinen Spass zu haben, aber seit gestern ist mir das total auf den Sack gegangen, der 1. April, ich habe nur gehofft, dass er vorbei ist irgendwann, und dann hast du mir aber den Tag versüßt, weil du bist natürlich auf den besten April-Scherz reingefallen, den man überhaupt je machen kann. Es wurde ein neuer WoW-Film angeteasert, oh, yeah, endlich ist der Trailer für neuer WoW-Film raus. World of Warcraft, ja. World of Warcraft, das kennt man, glaube ich. Und du warst völlig außer dir, warst ganz fröhlich und da habe ich mich auch für dich ein bisschen mitgefreut, du sass neben mir in dem Moment, ich habe auch nicht gesehen genau, wie der Trailer dann ging, du hast aber so eine halbe Stunde lang nichts mehr gesagt und ich habe auch irgendwie völlig überall hinwegen weggekommen, wenn du das gesehen hast, bis du am Ende des Tages dann reumütig zugegeben hast, dass es ein erster April-Schatz war und darauf reingefallen bist. Ja, ich weiß schon, ich wollte das sogar gross machen, wir waren da in der Redaktion und die ganze Redaktion war anwesend und ich war kurz davor, es sogar gross zu machen und zu sagen, hey Leute, wir müssen uns unbedingt den neuen World of Warcraft-Trailer anschauen, schmeiss es auf den Bildschirm, ja, ganz gross zu machen, um dann öffentlich geschämt zu werden, dass es nicht funktioniert.
Aber ich war früher tatsächlich auch ein Prankster als Kind und habe immer Pranks gespielt, die aber oft nicht so ganz funktioniert haben, wie es mir dachte. Und ich hatte das Mickey Mouse Magazin abonniert und die haben sich natürlich immer was Tolles ausgedacht für den 1. April, dass man tolle Pranks machen kann. Und in einer Ausgabe war so ein Plastiknagel, der so aus zwei Teilen bestand, die man an so eine Glasscheibe kleben konnte, also in einen Teil innen, den anderen Teil außen. Und dann gab es noch so einen Plastiksticker dazwischen, der dann so aussah, als wäre das Glas gesprungen, so als hätte man da einen Nagel durchgeschlagen. Und dann sollte man dann so, oh nein, das Fenster ist kaputt und die Mutter rastet aus und dann, nein, war nur ein Streich. Und ich dachte mir, ich mache das in so einem Küchenschrank, mach ich das und lass das dann einfach da so liegen.
Also dann die Mutter soll da schon selber draufstoßen, weil wenn am 1. April dein Kind zu dir kommt und sagt, nein, Mutter, mit mässigen Schauspielqualitäten, Kinder sind sehr schlechte Schauspieler.
Ja.
Ja, und wenn du was sagen willst, dann sag was, okay? Und nicht so viele dumme Geräusche, wenn es geht, okay? Ich bin gerade mitten in der Story drin.
Okay, sorry, ich wollte einfach diese These ein bisschen relativieren mit einem. Oh, na ja, also so ein Handwackeln, so ein vokales Handwackeln. Und tatsächlich habe ich es dann hängen gelassen und habe den ganzen Tag nur drauf gewartet und habe mir die Hände gerieben, bis irgendwann meine Mutter anfängt zu schreien aus der Küche. Allerdings der erste April ... Weil die Milch abgelaufen war. Der erste April verstrich und meine Mutter hat es nicht entdeckt. Und 2. April morgens stand ich immer noch vor dem Küchenstrang und habe geguckt und dann dachte ich mir, hm, soll ich das jetzt wieder abmachen und es einfach gewesen lassen sein? Warum schreit deine Mutter denn? Meine Mutter hat es einfach nicht entdeckt. Meine Mutter hat einfach nicht entdeckt den Tag. Sie hat nicht geschrien? Nein, überhaupt nichts passiert, gar nicht. Ach so, sie hat geschrien? Nein, nein, nein, es ist einfach nichts passiert passiert und der Tag war vorbei und dann dachte ich mir, ja gut, dann baue ich es wieder ab, dann wird die Folie wieder abgezogen, Plastiknagel wieder genommen, weggeworfen und das war's, das war der 1. April. Aber warum lässt es nie, dass wir da hängen? Ja, weil ich dachte, am 2. April zählt es nicht mehr, nein. Wieso zählt es nicht mehr? Weiß ich nicht mehr, für mich hat es schon so ein Teil mehr. Das ist auch so typisch deutsche Scheisse ist das, dass man nur am 1. April zählt es nicht mehr. Wieso zählt es nicht mehr? Weiß ich nicht mehr. Das ist auch so typisch deutsche Scheiße, ist das. Dass man nur am 1. April Scherze machen darf, und am 2. dann ist es nicht mehr erlaubt. Diese Denke ist falsch, dass es kleben lassen müssen. Am 4. wäre es auch noch lustig gewesen. Am 5. wäre es kritisch geworden, am 6. furchtbar. Das stimmt. Ich habe heute für die Aufnahme extra eine Perücke angezogen, um den kleinen Streich zu spielen, aber es geht auch noch hinten los. Naja, Scham. Sexualität ist ja so ein Thema, für das sich viele Leute schämen, wo man gewisse Unsicherheiten hat, man weiß nicht, ist mein Körper in Ordnung, weiß ich, was ich tue, ne, gibt es viele Unsicherheiten, die da Menschen haben. Da habe ich heute gehört, ja, ja, ja, da habe ich heute gehört, dass es sehr, dass besonders Leute, die in Mannschaftssportarten aufwachsen, ein gesunderes Verhältnis zu ihrem Körper haben, weil sie den ja öfter beim Duschen zeigen. Habe ich heute die These gehört. Ja, kann ich mir vorstellen. Ja. Beide waren aber nicht in Mannschaftssportarten, oder sehe ich das richtig? Doch, ich war kurz im Fußball, habe ich ja mal erzählt. Ah, und hast du ein gutes Verhältnis zu deinem Körper? Absolut nicht. Ich war wahrscheinlich zu kurz drin. Man muss eine gewisse Grenze überschreiten wahrscheinlich. Okay, verstehe. Ja. Hast du denn gesunde Stolz? Ich wollte einfach nur mal so dieses Schämen im Podcast einfach mal ein bisschen darstellen. Tatsächlich ist mir letztens was aufgefallen. Und zwar finde ich ja ganz, also ich bin ein großer Fan von Pornos, jetzt nicht nur den Konsum derselben, sag ich mal der zweckmässige Konsum, sondern auch so ein bisschen als Analyseobjekt des Zeitgeistes und wie menschliche Psyche funktioniert und wie Lust und Begierde funktioniert und was es für Fetische gibt und so. Ich finde das eine spannende Richtung, in die wir gerade einschlagen. Ja, absolut. Aber ich finde, es gibt manchmal schon so einen Comedy-Faktor bei Pornos. Manchmal schaut man sich das an und diese Absurdität lässt sich dann auch nicht ganz verschweigen. Und ich, also ich bin, finde ich immer sehr-Pornos, wenn so irgendwie zwanzig Männer in einem Raum sind, eine Frau, zwanzig Männer und eine Frau hat jetzt nur gewisse Kapazitäten, mit Männern umzugehen, das heißt, es kommen oft nicht alle Männer zum Zug. Das heißt, man hat so zwischen sieben und acht Männer tatsächlich am Werk und interessant, wesentlich interessanter finde ich die Männer, die gerade nicht am Werk sind, sondern die im Hintergrund stehen, sich wild einen runterholen. Ja, ja, das sind die Klassiker. Sich wild einen runterholen und mit diesem Blick des, komme ich noch dran heute, komme ich, soll ich noch, oder? Das sind doch meistens die, wo man nicht genau weiß, werden die jetzt noch dafür bezahlt oder haben die sich irgendwie reingekauft, wie bei diesen neuen Crowdfunding-Projekten, wo man sich noch reinkaufen kann, so eine Statistenrolle erkaufen kann. Ist das noch sowas oder haben die kriegen die noch Geld dafür? Ich glaube, die kriegen schon Geld dafür, aber ich finde es toll und manchmal in so einem Porno entsteht ja so ein persönlicher Moment, dann schaut einer von diesen im Hintergrund massivilden Menschen in die Kamera und es entsteht ein kurzer Blickkontakt zu diesem Mann und man denkt sich, im Grunde machen wir beide exakt dasselbe, wir holen uns einen runter und schauen Leuten dabei zu, wie sie Sex haben. Es entsteht so ein kleiner freundschaftlicher Moment, man ist auf der gleichen Seite. Aber sie lachen dann nicht. Nee, sie lachen überhaupt nicht. Sex und Lachen passt nicht so gut zusammen. Ist oft ein Downer, ja. Ist ein Downer. Aber es ist immer ein schöner Moment und vor allem, ich weiß nicht, was geht einem Menschen vor, der holt sich da hinten runter und denkt, komm ich noch dran oder soll ich kurz in die Küche gehen und mir ein Sandwich machen oder soll ich kurz nochmal hochgehengehen und Fernsehen schauen oder bleibe ich hier? Ich glaube, ich mache mir jetzt die fünf Minuten-Theorie. Das habe ich noch. Ich glaube, das ist auch ein Quell für viel Charme tatsächlich auf so einem Porn... Nein, ich glaube nicht. Ich glaube, ganz im Gegenteil. Ich glaube, es gibt nie so wenig Charme wie auf einem Pornofilm drehen, glaube ich. Ich glaube, die haben... Also da frage ich mich wirklich, Pornodarstellerinnen, wo die dann zum Beispiel noch ihren Charme haben, also wo die Charme-Situationen erleben. Zum Beispiel beim Flughafen. Wenn der Koffer zu groß ist, tut mir leid, ich denke gerade nur daran, was machen die dann? Also regen die sich darüber auf, fühlen uns leid? Der Koffer anfängt zu vibrieren. Ja, genau. Haben die da noch Situationen, die sich da schämen oder würden die sich vielleicht auch ganz ausziehen?
Ich meine, den Marktscannern am Flughafen ein bisschen Arbeit abnehmen, einfach komplett blank ziehen und da durchgehen.
Würden die das machen oder haben die da ihre Probleme? Oder trennen die auch beruflich von Privatem und sind privat schamvoll? Ich glaube schon tatsächlich. Also es ist ja auch so, ich meine, man kennt das ja selber irgendwie, dass man professionell irgendwie anders mit Leuten umgeht als privat. Also so professionell ist es ja schon mal was anderes. Hatten wir schon mal, du bist privat sehr unlustig und sehr ernst.
Ja, extrem, ich bin ein total unlustiger, ernster Typ, ich bin sehr, ich schaue mir den ganzen Tag Pornos an und versuche Freuds Theorien zu durchdenken anhand von Pornos.
Und beruflich bin ich ein absoluter Kracher und brauche dann immer relativ lange im Privaten, um mit Menschen warm zu werden.
Aber was ich auch tatsächlich sehr interessant finde und sind, also es gibt ja verschiedene Fetische bei Pornos in verschiedenen Kategorien und da gibt es die kategorie incest ja also incest situationen zum beispiel irgendwie vater mit tochter und in dem porno wird auch ganz klar dargestellt dass es sich hier um vater und tochter handelt also das wird ganz klar offen ausgesprochen aber im porno titel steht dann trotzdem noch irgendwie horny father fucks not his daughter und not ganz gross in Caps geschrieben. Und das finde ich tatsächlich hochinteressant, warum das dann da steht. Aber das finde ich aber auch interessant. Das ist ja eine redaktionelle, journalistische Arbeit, die Titel sich auszudenken und die Beschreibungen sich auszudenken und hinzuschreiben. Aber meistens ist es eine grosse Textbildschere. Absolut, na vor allem, ich meine, es ist ja eigentlich erst mal irrelevant, du musst ja nicht hinschreiben, irgendwie Typ fickt nicht seine Tochter. So warum sollte man davon ausgehen, dass es seine Tochter ist? Es sind da draußen Leute, die nach Kants Regeln handeln und moralisch richtig versuchen, an die Sache ranzugehen und die sich dann vielleicht kein Porno angucken würden, der Inzest beworben. Ja, aber warum wird ein Produkt mit seinem genauen Gegenteil beworben? Warum schreibt man in die Titel, hier gibt es genau kein Inzest und im Porno gibt es genau Inzest? Warum? Ist es eine moralische Hürde, dann zu sagen, oh, ich klicke hier drauf, ist ja kein Inzest und na gut, jetzt bin ich schon dabei, hab kurz überhört, aber ich meine, Leute klicken das ja an, weil sie den Fetisch für Inzest haben oder weil sie das Szenario geil finden, sich aber trotzdem das nicht hundertprozentig eingestehen können und wahrscheinlich eher auf die Titel klicken, wo es dann eher tatsächlich nicht ganz klar beworben wird. Aber das finde ich hochinteressant, weil das ist ja, man sucht ja aktiv nach Inzest und man sucht ja dann nach Father, Daughter oder sowas, findet dann die, aber da steht, Father fucks not his daughter, und das klickt man dann an und will aber sehen, wie der Vater mit seiner Tochter schläft. Also das finde ich total verrückt, wobei ich mir überlegt habe, vielleicht ist damit ja auch gesagt, dass es nicht wirklich Vater und Tochter sind, sondern Schauspieler, die Vater und Tochter spielen, was in meinen Augen trivial zu erwähnen ist, weil natürlich ist das nicht echte Vater und Tochter, ist ja klar, aber dass man sich dadurch vielleicht ein bisschen von seinem schlechten Gewissen erholen kann, zu sagen, ja, die spielen das dann über, aber echt sind es die nicht, obwohl es eigentlich bei Pornos immer so sind. Ich glaube, es gibt relativ wenige echte Pizzalieferanten in Pornos. Na ja, Moment, ganz kurz. Ich muss dich ganz so ein bisschen entschleunigen. Du hast jetzt von Amateurpornos gesprochen, gehe ich da da recht in der Annahme? Naja, ich finde, es ist heute schwer zu trennen, was Amateur-Pornos in die Geschichte ist. Heutzutage guckt die Jugend und die Generation, die Porno-Generation, guckt ja, sagen wir mal, Internetsachen, die leicht zugänglich, kostenlos sind und meistens halt dementsprechend nicht auf einem hohen visuellen sowie dramaturgischen Standard.
Früher ist man ja noch in die Videothek gegangen, ist in die U-18-Abteilung gegangen,
hat sich noch umgeguckt, dass nicht der Nachbar gerade sieht, wenn man da reingeht.
Und dann hat man da sich was ausgesucht, was wahrscheinlich Schauspieler gemacht haben und so.
Aber da hat man ja was für bezahlt, das war wahrscheinlich nur Qualitätsindustrie.
Mittlerweile ist es ja nur noch so eine brachliegende was auch immer. Und ich glaube nicht, dass da grossartig geschauspielert wird. Na, das weiß ich nicht. Da werden ja keine Talente. Ich bin ja dem Begriff Amateurporno so ein bisschen skeptisch gegenüber, weil ich glaube schon, dass da relativ häufig professionelle Anbieter dahinterstehen. Vielleicht nicht unbedingt professionelle Schauspieler, aber glaube ich tatsächlich schon ab und zu. Wobei ich mich da in der Bezahl-Pornoszene tatsächlich sehr schlecht auskenne, also ob es dann neben der Amateurwelt noch die Bezahlwelt gibt oder ob das so ein bisschen ineinander übergeht. Aber ich habe tatsächlich, ein Freund von mir hatte schon mal ein Jahr lang ein Abo bei so einer Edel-Porno-Seite und da habe ich auch mir einige runtergeladen, von daher merkt man schon einen Unterschied. Das ist schon was anderes, wobei ich tatsächlich die Amateur-Pornos interessanter finde als diese Hochglanz-Pornos, weil ich will eigentlich kein Porno schauen, sondern man will, das ist genau der gleiche Effekt wie mit dem Inzesting, man will keinen Porno anschauen. Du hast auch wenig Charme, du hast auch wenig Charme, du redest gerade offen zu Millionen Leuten, ich weiß nicht genau, wir können die Abrufzahlen nicht sehen, aber ich gehe mal davon aus, vom Millionenpublikum redest du gerade davor, wie du dir Pornos anguckst. Naja, aber das ist ja kein Geheimnis, dass ich mir Pornos angucke. Ich würde nicht. Naja, natürlich, weil jeder Mensch sich Pornos anschaut, obwohl da können wir gleich auch nochmal über ein anderes Thema sprechen. Aber, naja, ich meine, mir wäre es schon peinlich jetzt zu sagen, welche Pornos ich mir genau anschaue, aber dass ich Pornos anschaue, finde ich jetzt nicht so. Schaust du denn Pornos an, Stefan? Nein, absolut nicht, gar kein bisschen. Okay, alles klar. Ich würde tatsächlich mal gern ein Porno durch die Augen einer Frau sehen, wie das ist. Das ist ja die grosse Diskussion, schauen Frauen Pornos an mehr oder weniger. Ja, aber das ist krass, das ist eine triviale Diskussion. Das ist eine triviale Frage, aber trotzdem habe ich immer das Gefühl, dass Pornos so komplett auf einen männlichen Betrachter ausgelegt sind, so Produkte von Männer für Männer. Es gibt ja auch dann diese extra Frauenpornos, die dann so von Frauen produziert werden, aber da sich die nicht wirklich durchsetzen, glaube ich, dass die nicht so gut ankommen. Und ich glaube, würde man wirklich Frauen eine Alternative bieten, die die Frauen auch haben wollen, würden die sich auch durchsetzen, weil es, auch wenn die weniger Frauen Pornos schauen als Männer, gibt es dann trotzdem noch 30 Prozent Frauenkund, was immer noch ein sehr grosser Markt ist. Deswegen, also das finde ich so interessant, das ist so wie, also kennst du diese Fernsehsendungen, wo irgendwie einem Typen so ein Traum erfüllt wird, für einen Tag, da ist grosser Formel-1-Fan und dann darf er mal auf dem Nürnbergring, trifft Sebastian Vettel und darf in einem Auto fahren und so, alle Träume werden erfüllt. Und für mich, ich stelle es mir vor, wenn eine Frau in Porno schaut, ist es genau so, nur die Redaktion hat irgendwo ein bisschen die Interessen verwechselt, so, der interessiert sich gar nicht für Formel 1, so, das ist so, wenn du dich eigentlich, du interessierst dich total für die Simpsons und die Redaktion vertauscht es aber und du kriegst den Oboen-Liebhabertag und kannst den ganzen Tag mit Oboen verbringen, du kriegst die beste Oboe der Welt, du triffst Hraflaff Helmi, den besten Oboen-Spieler der Welt, du triffst Fabian von Ferensteise, den grössten Nachwuchstalent im Oboen-Spiel, du stehst auf der Bühne, musst dann aber sagen, das ist echt alles sehr geil, Leute, aber Oboen interessieren mich halt überhaupt nicht. Aber wenn sie mich interessieren würden, wäre es supergut. Also so ein bisschen stelle ich mir das vor, wenn eine Frau in Pornos schaut. Es ist alles da, es ist alles gut, aber interessiere mich halt jetzt nicht so für die männliche Perspektive. Oder ich weiss auch nicht, ob es anders ist oder ob Frauen etwas anderes daraus ziehen. Ich weiss es nicht, keine Ahnung. Ich bin gerade ein bisschen geschockt, dass du so auf einmal dieses Thema einschlägst, wovon ich gar nicht drauf gefasst heute. Ja, ich dachte, wir reden heute mal über ein bisschen intimere Sachen. Es geht ja um Scham tatsächlich. Ist ja gut, okay. Peinlichkeiten. Hast du mal irgendwie, du bist ja auch oft in der Öffentlichkeit, du bist oft im Fernsehen zu sehen, dann hast du bestimmt auch mal, also gerade Dreharbeiten, wo du ja auch oft so eine Schamgrenze überspringen musst, so eine gewisse Hemmschwelle, die man hat. Hast du da was erlebt, irgendwas völlig Peinliches? Nee, bei Dreharbeiten nicht, aber ich war letztens auf einem Olli-Schulz-Konzert.
Okay, das ist nie gelöst, das ist nicht schlecht.
Teppich unter den Füssen weggezogen.
Okay, wir waren beide auf dem Olli-Schulz-Konzert.
Auf die Gästeliste wurden wir gesetzt, weil wir uns draufgequengelt haben, waren sehr stolz darauf, wir waren sehr glücklich, dass wir da noch mit konnten.
Eigentlich war es nicht schon voll und irgendwie hat Olli Schulz da noch 50 Leute auf die Gästeliste geschrieben, gab ein bisschen Ärger, aber er ist halt ein Streeter Typ, der bei den kleinen Leuten, bei uns den kleinen Leuten noch gut gesonnen ist. Und dann konnten wir da hin, haben uns das Konzert angeguckt und wir hatten auch Backstage-Pässe. Wir haben von dem Voranstalter so Backstage-Pässe bekommen, weil wir auf der Gästeliste standen und wir waren da sehr glücklich drüber und wollten dann unbedingt nochmal diese Chance mitnehmen. Wo man aber auch ganz kurz sagen muss, dass Backstage-Pass in der Theorie, die Idee eines Backstage-Passes ist sehr, sehr cool. Man denkt sich, ich habe einen Backstage-Pass, das ist was Cooles. In der Realität allerdings war das einfach ein Sticker, den man sich auf die Brust kleben musste. Das ist auch die uncoolste Art, so etwas zu tragen. Man stellt sich vor, so ein Band um den Hals, total cool, man zeigt es dann, nee, einfach so ein scheiss Sticker wie auf einem Treffen.
Naja, erstmal ist das so eine Karte, wie so eine Karte. Und dann haben wir halt nach der Show, wir wussten nicht, wo der Backstagebereich war, wahrscheinlich hinter der Bühne, also sind wir in Richtung Bühne gegangen, haben den Security-Guy gefragt, ja, so, wir würden jetzt gerne hier, ist mein Backstagepass, ja, ich bin's wirklich, bleibt ruhig sitzen und dann zeig uns mal mal, wo der Backstagebereich ist, füllen uns nochmal hin und dann er so, nee, nee, klebt den erstmal auf und dann fing es erst an, dass ich verstanden habe, dass es ein Sticker ist und dann musstest du ihn wirklich so richtig demütigend irgendwo hinkleben und er sieht auch nicht wirklich geil aus. Was du jetzt bis dahin schon verschwiegen hast, war, dass ich auf euch beiden anderen Dödeln, wir waren ja noch mit einem anderen Kollegen da und auch noch einem anderen Kollegen, dass ich auf euch drei Dödeln erstmal eine halbe Stunde darauf einreden musste, weil ihr, nein, wir trauen uns nicht im Backstage-Bereich, was sollen wir denn da machen, was sollen wir denn da machen, ja komm, ja, die Prominenten waren schon weg, die es verdient hätten, da im Backstage-Bereich zu sitzen, nicht wir kleinen Menschen. Ja, man, Backstage passt ja dann, geht immer noch im Backstage. Ja, haben wir dann auch gesagt, nein, ihr müsst heute mal über euren Schatten springen, ihr könnt euch nicht immer für alles schämen, ihr müsst auch einfach mal euer Schicksal in die eigene Hand nehmen und ein Abenteuer eingehen, verdammt auch mal. Du bist ein Risk-Taker, du bist ein Risk-Taker. Ich bin ein Risk-Taker, ich bin ein High-Flyer, all das. Slow-Grower. So was, ja. So, auf jeden Fall. Und dann haben wir mit dem gesprochen und er hat gesagt, ja okay, dann stellt euch mal da rechts an die Wand und dann werdet ihr abgeholt. Und das ist so ein, das ist, gibt es nicht auch dieses Sprichwort, man wird an die Wand gestellt? Na gut, vielleicht gibt es nicht, vielleicht sollten wir das noch erfinden. Wir wurden jedenfalls richtig demütigend an die Wand gestellt. Man muss sich vorstellen, wir sind erst richtig stolz, haben wir unsere Backstage-Presse hochgehalten, mit der Nase hoch sind wir in Richtung Bühne gewandert, alle Leute haben uns bewundert, oh, was aber, die sind befreundet, die sind Cousins von Olli Schulz, Wahnsinn, und dann wurden wir halt sehr demütigend an der Wand geparkt.
Ja, aber im Sichtbereich von allen anderen Zuschauern, die noch da waren, durften wir durch so eine Absperrung durch, was total cool ist, und alle kommen zu anderen, wer ist das, und dann stehen wir da die ganze Zeit rum und lassen uns erstmal so begaffen wie Tiere, und dann dachten wir, ja, okay, gut, wir stehen jetzt eine Minute rum, irgendwie cool, unterhalten uns ein bisschen mit einem Security-Typen und dann kommt irgendwie Olli Schulz, Managerin, holt uns ab und wir kommen in den Backstage-Bereich und haben einfach eine gute Zeit, weißt du, ein bisschen geile Show, man wirft sich Komplimente hin und her, man spielt mal ein bisschen auf dem Pass. Richtenpack, Gratis-Drinks. Ja genau, vielleicht werden auch der ein oder andere Rauschkraut konsumiert, ja man weiss es ja nicht, was so passieren kann auf so einem Backstage-AbAm, da kann ja alles passieren. Also Salbei-Bonbons mein Sohn. Was letztendlich passiert ist ... Es kam jemand, breitgrinsend, auf uns gackernde Hühner zugelaufen, wir natürlich an der Wand geparkt, haben die Diskussion weitergeführt, sollten wir jetzt wirklich da reingehen, wir haben anscheinend wirklich keine Autorität, keinerlei, wir wurden nämlich an die Wand gestellt, und dann kam ein breit grinsender Security-Mensch auf uns zu und hat gesagt, nee, ihr dürft heute leider nicht mehr rein, wir holen keinen mehr rein. Und das war dann das Ende des Abends, wir wurden einfach abgewiesen. Und es hat mich natürlich auch mit einer Einstellung bekräftigt, dass es einfach keine Gerechtigkeit gibt in dieser Welt. Weil ich stand da, wie Aragorn vor seinen Soldaten, hab geschrien, nein, wir bleiben zum Beispiel, weil ihr drei Dödel wolltet. Nein, wir gehen, das ist so peinlich, ich schäme mich so sehr. Nein, das stimmt ja gar nicht. Nütze den Charme als Antrieb. Frodo hat sich auch geschämt, als er Dings gemacht hat. Du stellst dich gerade so da, als du so Braveheart-mäßig so eine geile Rede gehalten hast. Du hast keine Braveheart-Rede gehalten. Doch, natürlich habe ich das. Du hast gesagt sowas wie, nee, komm, wir nehmen das jetzt mit, komm, wir nehmen das jetzt mit. Aber weißt du was, ich bin jetzt nur mit Attention Whore. Ich bin jetzt nur mit Attention Whore und muss dann unbedingt in den Backstage-Bereich gehen. Das muss für mich nicht sein. Ich bin noch mit dem Konzert zufrieden gewesen, bin dann nach Hause gegangen, schön, wäre ein lustiger Abend geworden und so müssen wir uns demütigen vor allerlei Menschen. Naja, auf jeden Fall war es das demütigendste, das demütigendste, wieder zurück zum Pöbel gehen aller Zeiten. Wir mussten wieder durch den ganzen halben Raum laufen, wieder durch die Absperrung durch und wieder unter das normale Volk. Mit diesen ekligen Aufklebern auch. Die allen zeigen, hey, wir haben es gewollt, aber wir haben es nicht geschafft. Ja, das stimmt. Das war wirklich furchtbar. Das Lustige war, wir haben auch Spass vorher noch gesagt, sehr laut natürlich, weil wir angeben wollten, dass wir diese Backstage-Besse hatten, haben wir sehr laut gesagt, ja, wir könnten die auch verkaufen einfach für tausend Euro oder so. Hätten wir es mal gemacht. Ja, nicht passiert. Tja, jetzt sind wir eine Erfahrung reicher, aber das hat auch dieses Schamgefühl, immer wenn man das hat, weiß man, also wenn man ein positiver Mensch ist, kann man das auch sehen als, das ist der Moment, irgendwann mal sage ich, das ist eine Erfahrung wert gewesen.
Ich finde, Scham ist ja tatsächlich eine quintessentielle Emotion des Menschen, weil Scham ist ja eigentlich das Gegenteil von Selbstbewusstsein.
Und eigentlich ist ja Selbstbewusstsein, hat ja wahnsinnig viel mit dem normalen Alltag zu tun, deswegen ist Scham da so ein bisschen der Gegenpol, das heißt, wenn du dich nicht traust, eine Frau anzusprechen, ist es letztendlich Scham. Wenn du dich nicht traust, nach einer Gehaltserhöhung zu fragen, ist es letztendlich Scham. Also ein Grossteil der wirklich wichtigen Dinge im Leben haben mit Scham zu tun. Ganz kurz, ich rieche gerade an meinem Mikrofon und es stinkt unfassbar, ich habe unfassbaren Mundgeruch gerade. Ich habe nämlich eine Knoblauchwurst heute gegessen, als Mittagessen, in der Redaktion. Warum?
Ja, es hat mich wieder angelacht, das ist ein Fehlkauf, das kennen wir ja schon, Folge
zwei, Zwinker, Zwinker.
Warte mal, gibst du mir mal ganz kurz fünf Minuten, ich bin in fünf Minuten wieder da.
Nein, nein. I said to wait, does an angel contemplate my faith, oh, and do they know the places where we go when we're gray and old? So when I'm lying in my bed, thoughts running through my hair, and I feel the love is there,
I'm loving Florentinen's stare, and through it, ah! So hoch kann ich leider nicht pfeifen.
Einsamkeit.
Einsamkeit zeigt, wie gut man mit sich selber im Reinen ist. Es ist der Spiegel zu dir selbst, der dir zeigt, wer du wirklich bist, wer du sein willst und wer du einmal warst. Stefan Diesel, Gedichtszyklus Nummer 23. Man hört im Hintergrund, was Florentin macht. Aber ich kann es nicht identifizieren. Ich glaube, er muss seine Hose wechseln. Da ist er wieder. Pst, da ist er wieder. Okay, ich bin wieder da. Okay, ja. Okay, los geht's. Nichts passiert in der Zeit. Cool. Wo waren wir? Was? Wie, was? Lena, meine Damen und Herren, meine Güte, dass Lena mal Landruth hier noch noch mal vorbeischaut, ist ein geklauter Gag, findest du jetzt noch nicht.
Stefan.
Nee, wie gesagt, ich habe heute eine Knoblauchwurst mehr gegessen als Mittagessen, Donut, ein Donut und Knoblauchwurst pur und es war, leider hat sich herausgestellt, dass es mehr Knoblauch als Wurst war und der ganze Raum hat dementsprechend geschwunken und ich habe jetzt das Problem, dass das Mikro, diesen Geruch aufzunehmen beginnt. Und ich habe auch ein bisschen Angst, dass es gleich bis zum Flug nicht ganz weggeht. Und ich meinen Flugnachbarn auf die Nerven gehe damit. Dafür würdest du dich dann schämen. Nur mal ganz kurz zum Thema Scham.porno. Interessant sind ja auch immer so diese Werbepop-Ups, die man dann so kriegt. Und was man relativ häufig kriegt, sind so Chat-Rooms, wo man dann von so einem Roboter, von so einem Computerprogramm... Man hat mit einem Bot angeschrieben und man kann antworten. Aber es ist tatsächlich sehr verlockend. Da steht dann so, hey, du warst die ganze Zeit schon nicht da, hey, woher kommst du denn, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne. Und dann habe ich mir letztes Mal... Und die fangen immer sehr nett an. Sehr, sehr nett an. Die wissen direkt, wo man herkommt. Absolut. Das ist dann direkt sympathisch, die wohnen meistens in der Nähe, das ist sympathisch, da kann man sich direkt über die Stadt unterhalten. Ja, sie sind geil, ja, das steht da schon, geile Frauen aus seiner Nähe, man muss nicht mehr herausfinden, ist die Frau geil oder nicht, steht da schon, man hat objektive Informationen. Ich bin geil. Ja, wunderbar, perfekte Kommunikation, aber ich habe mir letztens mal den Spaß gemacht, tatsächlich mal so einer jungen Dame zurückzuschreiben und man kann sich mit denen echt ganz gut unterhalten tatsächlich, die sind relativ clever. Was ich aber interessant finde, ist, dass die Gespräche zu nichts führen. Also man würde ja erwarten irgendwie so, hey, na, wie geht's dir, so, ja, hey, wollen wir uns kennenlernen, ja, klar, warum nicht, ja, schick mir doch mal eine E-Mail-Adresse, okay, hier, oh ja, ich brauche ein Zugticket, kannst du mir 100 Euro an die Adresse schicken, so, dass dann irgend so ein Betrugsding passiert, damit dieser Algorithmus, dieser Bot eine Funktion hat. Aber es passiert gar nichts. Man chattet einfach nur hin und her und hält sich nett. Und irgendwann berät sich das Gespräch im Kreis, irgendwann fängt sie wieder an, das zu schreiben, was sie am Anfang schon bespricht. Wo ich mir denke, es ist wirklich die perfekte Imitation, also ich bin es gewohnt so mit Frauen zu reden, es führt einfach zu nichts, ja, man ist immer nur hin und her dann ja, irgendwann gut, okay, tschau, mach's gut. Also die haben das schon perfekt getroffen, die Programmierer tatsächlich. Das ist das genaue Erlebnis perfekt eingefangen, das ist wundervoll. Aber ich frage mich tatsächlich, was da passieren muss, weil das ist ja wie in so Videospielen, dass man erst gewisse Bedingungen schaffen muss. Man muss da ganz kurz zu sagen, dass immer, wenn du irgendwie eine Seite aufmachst, in deinem Browser, an deinem Laptop, dass immer so komische Seiten aufploppen bei dir, weil du anscheinend ein Virus drauf hast. Ja, ich habe ein Virus, das irgendwie alle 20 Minuten zwei Pop-Ups von irgendjemandem haben. Und du brauchst dich aber nicht zu wundern, was du dieses Virus hast, wenn du immer diesen ganzen netten reizenden Damen antwortest. Ich weiß, die Verlockung ist groß, aber vielleicht sollte man davon absehen. Ja, ich kenne mich mittlerweile mit solchen Pop-ups sehr, sehr gut aus, tatsächlich. Aber ich meine, irgendwann vergisst man auch, dass man mit so einem Roboter spricht. Irgendwann kann man sich einfach ganz nett unterhalten, das ist eigentlich sehr, sehr schön. Aber es ist ja wie in so einem Videospiel, wo man erst gewisse Bedingungen herstellen muss, damit irgendwas passiert. Man muss erst mit der Person gesprochen haben, damit da eine Tür aufgeht und man kommt weiter. Und ich dachte, so ist es bei denen auch, dass man gewisse Schlagworte erwähnen muss, bis sie dann irgendwie die Falle zuschnappen lassen und sagen so, hey, schick mir mal dein ganzes Geld an XY. Deswegen habe ich verschiedene Worte versucht einzugeben, es hat aber nichts gebracht. Ich bin nicht weitergekommen, ich brauche irgendwie, ich brauche, ich brauche, ich brauche zu einem Flirttraining. Ich habe denen meine Kontonummer geschickt und es hat nichts gebracht. Ich habe denen meine Kartennummer, meine Sozialversicherung. Und es hat dir nichts abgebucht, Idioten.
Man müsste mal zu so einem Flirttraining gehen und sagen, mit normalen Frauen überhaupt kein Problem, kein Stress, aber diese Fake-Chat-Fonds, da kann ich nicht über mich hinauswachsen. Wenn man diese, wenn man so Mails bekommt, also diese typischen Viagra-Mails oder was auch immer, hier, ich habe 100.000 Euro gewonnen, du kannst es auch. Und dann kennen die ja deinen Namen sogar. Aber da verstehe ich niemandem nicht, da ist halt immer nur ein Link in der Mail. Und wenn man den anklickt, ist man da auf einer Seite, die aber halt auch eine Fake-Seite ist. Dann hast du schon verloren. Naja, aber du hast aber auch kein Virus drauf. Also ich habe da nie verstanden, warum, bis mir mal irgendwer erklärt hat, dass so Test-Mails sind von Drittanbietern, die deine Mailadresse weiterverkaufen wollen. Ah, ob die Seite aktiv ist. Genau, die wollen wissen, ob der Mail-Account, den du benutzt, ob du den benutzt oder nicht. Und wenn du den benutzt, das heißt, wenn du auf diesen Link geklickt hast, musst du ja die Mail gelesen haben, dann ist deine Mailadresse mehr wert im Weiterverkauf. Ach, verstehe, das ist ja hochinteressant. Wissen to go, das waren die schlauen 30 Sekunden. Fantastisch, sehr, sehr gut, das gefällt mir sehr gut. Soll ich noch mal erklären, wie Licht funktioniert? Ich habe letztens ein Jobangebot bekommen per Mail und halt irgendwie, ja, irgendwie, wir haben sie schon länger beobachtet, bla bla bla, wir bieten ihnen 2500 Euro Monatsgehalt. Das Problem, in der gesamten Mail stand nicht der Name der Firma. Wo ich mir auch denke, das ist ein kleiner Anfänger für ihr, Leute. Wenn ihr schon so ein Fake-Ding rausschreibt, womit man einfach die erste Frage, die man sich sofort stellt bei Sie haben ein Jobangebot, ist wo? Bei welcher Firma? Wo soll ich arbeiten? Was soll ich machen? Und wenn diese Frage nicht beantwortet wird, dann gibt es ein Problem. Dann ist da irgendwas falsch. Neulich bei irgendeiner Newsseite, ich weiß nicht, Buzzfeed oder so, da war auch die sehr lustige Geschichte geschrieben, dass in den Staaten ein berühmter Mailbetrüger endlich geschnappt wurde und hinter Gittern gebracht wurde. Und der spricht wirklich so, wie diese Mails geschrieben sind, der spricht wirklich so. Ja, was war das für ein milder Gag? Jedenfalls wurde da ein ... Hat die Verheingehende? Unfassbar scheisse. Ich würde eine Eins von zehn geben. Das war eine Frechheit. Wenn Leute da jetzt wütend in der U-Bahn stehen, unseren Podcast hörend, die regen sich auf. Du hast den jetzt in Weinen. Ich möchte mich entschuldigen für die ... Du hast eine Träne in den Augen gezaubert. Es wäre lustiger gewesen, wenn ich jetzt tatsächlich ein Beispiel hätte, wie diese Leute sprechen.
Ja, und jedenfalls wurde der dann geschnackt, in der Gitter gebracht, und er hat sich, er hat dann eine Mail geschickt, wo er, er hat eine Mail quasi betrogen, wo er seine Freilassung dadurch erwirkt hat. Das heisst, und er ist mittlerweile wieder frei, weil die darauf reingefallen sind, weil er hat irgendwie geschrieben, ja, hier ist die und die Kommune und ich bin Herr so und so, der sich um Recht kümmert, Abteilung Recht und der und der ist freigesprochen. Und er hat quasi mit dem einzigen Mittel, das er zur Verfügung hatte und wo man hätte darauf kommen müssen, dass er vielleicht nur dieses Mittel anwendet, das hat er benutzt, um sich freizubekommen. Wie gut ist das denn? Ja, wirklich, das passiert auch. Die ist die Welt nicht lustig. Wir haben den besten Fallensteller der Welt eingesperrt. Moment mal, was ist das eigentlich für ein Laubhaufen da hinten? Ich gehe mal nachsehen. Ja, es ist genau so. Unsere Welt ist unfassbar lustig. Wir sind schon auf der lustigsten Welt. Ja, glaube ich schon, auch in der lustigsten Dimension tatsächlich. Glaube ich, kann ich mir schon vorstellen. Ich hatte ja tatsächlich mal, also ich finde, peinliche Situationen sind immer schon okay als Gag. Aber interessant finde ich, wird es immer dann, wenn man in ähnlichen Situationen immer wieder peinliche Situationen hat. Wie zum Beispiel, du hast einmal pro Woche eine peinliche Situation, aber diese peinliche Situation immer vor der gleichen Person. Und du musst dir denken, was muss diese Person für einen Eindruck von mir haben. So zum Beispiel geschehen in meiner Geburtsstadt mit dem Fahrradverkäufer dort, wo ich mir ein Fahrrad gekauft habe, weil es einfach total schlecht war. Und dann habe ich mir dieses Fahrrad ausgesucht und dann, also, du musst dir diesen Typen so vorstellen, das ist so ein richtiger Bein. Aber du hast ja so oft ein Fahrrad gekauft. Nee der immer die Speicher kaputt gegangen ist, aber ich habe mir auf jeden Fall ein neues Fahrrad gekauft. Der hätte man vielleicht auch auf ein neues Fahrrad, genau. Ja, und dann habe ich mir ein neues Fahrrad gekauft und das ist so ein richtiger pragmatischer Bayer, das ist so ein schnörkelloser, irgendwie so ein Mountainbiker, na, geh mal ein bisschen Biken am Wochenende, so, weißt du, der interessiert sich für nichts anderes außer Biken, weißt du, die Berge, die Sonne und der ist halt so ein richtig sportlicher Typ und jeder, der seinen Laden betritt und Übergewicht hat, ist ihm erstmal skeptisch, so, na, gehst du nicht jeden Tag Biken oder was? So, das ist direkt schon mal eine ganz andere Welt, da kann er sich überhaupt nicht hineindenken, ja, das ist schon mal ganz fremd. So, und dann komme ich da eben angewackelt und sage, hallo, ja, ich will ein Fahrrad, ja, und dann, ja, ist mir eigentlich egal, wer ich ist, so, ich habe 50 Euro dabei, was haben Sie denn da? und dann sollte dieses Fahrrad Probe fahren. Und dann sind wir in den Hof rausgegangen und dann sollte ich da so ein bisschen rumfahren. Und dann steige ich direkt auf dieses Fahrrad, lege erstmal direkt den falschen Gang ein, stemme mich so hoch, will reintreten, zack, durchgetreten, Kette springt raus, ich schlage direkt auf dem Sattel auf und falle um. Ja, wirklich der schlechtmöglichste erste Album.
Slapstick, Classic Comedy. Das Tolle ist, wenn ich die andere Person gewesen hätte, hätte ich gelacht, irgendwie so, ja, ja, kann schon mal passieren, kein Problem. Aber er hat völlig ernste Miene, still steht wirklich, als würde er von Massmenschen stehen, weil er damit auch nichts anfangen kann mit dieser Tollpattigkeit. Er hat keinen Platz mehr im Leben für Tollpattigkeit. das ist das Schlimmste, ich finde, wenn da was Peinliches passiert, wenn man hinfällt vor Leuten und die lachen, ist das okay, es ist verkraftbar. Aber sobald die ernst bleiben und versuchen, diese Peinlichkeit auch zu überspielen irgendwie, indem sie da komplett keine Regung zeigen, das ist das Schlimmste, das macht es unendlich fach schlimmer. Ja, und vor allem dann später gab es nochmal die Situation, ich habe das Fahrrad irgendwie zwei Wochen gefahren und es war total kaputt und die Bremsen haben nicht mehr funktioniert. Und die Bremsen haben nur so ganz schlecht funktioniert und man musste so ganz lange bremsen, bis man überhaupt zum Stehen gekommen ist. Und dann gab es mal so einen regnerischen Tag und sein Fahrradladen war genau an so einem Hang, der geendet ist in einer Strassenkreuzung. Das heißt, man musste auf diesem Hang ganz stark bremsen. Und ich bin eines morgens da hingefahren, war schon zu spät zur Schule, bin relativ schnell gefahren, bin diesen Hang runter gefahren und habe gemerkt, ich schaff's nicht mehr, ich hab die Bremse voll durch, ich schaff's nicht mehr, richtig anzukommen an die Strassenkreuzung, das kann ja wirklich gefährlich werden, wenn man einfach so drauf fährt und dann ist man einfach tot. Und deswegen dachte ich mir, fuck, was mache ich? Und der Hang auf der anderen Seite, linken Seite war dieser Fahrrad lagen, auf der rechten Seite war komplett eine Hecke. Und da dachte ich mir einfach, ich fahre einfach in diese Hecke rein, weil das hat relativ gut aufgehalten. Und ich komme auf jeden Fall zum Stehen, deswegen nehme ich so ein bisschen so einen Schwung und fahre einfach voll Lotte in diese Hecke rein. Und hänge dann in der Hecke drin und schaue dann nur mich um und höre von oben so, ja, alles in Ordnung. und ich schaue hoch und dann steht natürlich genau derselbe Typ wieder da. Und ich so, ja, okay, alles okay, mit fünf Blättern im Mund, irgendwie überall essen, ja, ja, ist okay. Aber der Typ muss echt einen Eindruck von mir gehabt haben, zweimal in meinem Leben habe ich ihm begegnet und zweimal eine katastrophale Unangehensituation, wo ich mir echt denke, wenn man den Typen fragen würde, sag mal, du, dieser Florentin Will, was ist das eigentlich so für ein Typ, was würde der sagen, der kann doch nur sagen, das ist der grösste Vollidiot der Welt, nur schlechte Erfahrungen wird ihm gemacht. Du hast gerade während du hast erzählt, ist auch eine sehr peinliche Geschichte damals von ganz früher eingefallen, die habe ich glaube ich noch nie irgendwo erzählt, weil die mir immer noch ein bisschen peinlich ist, obwohl es ewig her ist und ich glaube ich hau die jetzt einfach mal raus. Exclusive! Es ist damals, es ist wirklich schon, ich weiß nicht wie lange her, zehn Jahre bestimmt, da war ich mit einem Mädchen auf einer Schaukel und in die war ich auch so ein bisschen verliebt. Wie lange ist es her, wie alt warst du? Zwölf oder so. Zwölf, okay. Elf, zwölf, ja, ein bisschen, vielleicht auch ein bisschen älter schon. Vielleicht war es auch letzte Woche erst. Ne, wir waren ein bisschen länger her. Und dann habe ich, war ich mit diesem Mädchen, habe ich mich dann getroffen und dann sind wir auf eine Schaukel gegangen, auf so eine, auf diese, was war das, diese, diese, kennt man ja, wo man zu zweit rein kann, diese, diese grossen Schaukeln. So diese Gondelförmigen Schaukeln, nein, ne, schon so wie halt eine Schaukel halt ist, nur halt für zwei Personen, das kennt man doch. Ja, ist okay, ja, kann man sich vorstellen, ja, ist okay. Und dann haben wir so geredet, genau, Love Swing, dann haben wir so ein bisschen geredet und dann habe ich nur plötzlich gepupst, also ich habe aus Versehen gepupst. Das ist, und das ist wirklich sehr unangenehm gewesen, weil es auch gar nicht ins Gespräch passte. Also es passte selten ins Gespräch, aber es war halt ein sehr romantisches Gespräch. Ich habe mich auch eigentlich gefreut und dann ist es halt passiert. Und dann wusste ich nicht, wie man das jetzt überspielen soll am besten. Und es hat dir doch keine Regeln gezeigt, so ähnlich wie dein Biker-Kollege, und dann habe ich versucht, so zu tun, als wäre das Geräusch halt nicht so entstanden, sondern anders, und habe dann die ganze Zeit versucht, mit meinem Mund das Geräusch nachzuahmen, so nach dem Motto, ja, das ist kein Furz gewesen, sondern das Geräusch habe ich eben aus Versehen mit dem Mund gemacht. Das ist natürlich auch irgendwie peinlich, aber halt wesentlich weniger peinlich. Und dann habe ich die ganze Zeit, also fünf Minuten lang war es Schweigen irgendwie und ich habe aber nur versucht, in fünf Minuten Geräusche mit meinem Mund zu machen, die das nicht nachahmen. Die schlechtmöglichste Entscheidung. Und das hat es viel schlimmer gemacht alles noch. Und dann war irgendwie die Schaukelheit auch schnell vorbei und die Wege haben sich getrennt. Und es ist wahnsinnig peinlich gewesen. Also es ist rückend immer noch wahnsinnig peinlich. Und wenn du mich jetzt sehen könntest, ich glaube, ich wäre ein bisschen rot.
Tatsächlich.
Oh, ach Mensch.
Aber schon, man sollte Peinlichkeiten eigentlich deswegen, das ist meine Lehre daraus, man
sollte Peinlichkeiten wirklich nicht versuchen zu überspielen.
Es macht's meistens noch schlimmer.
Nee, überhaupt nicht.
Aber Schaukeln sind tatsächlich auch ein schweres Gefilde.
Ich war auch mal in so einem Schauspielworkshop, da war ich auch noch relativ jung, irgendwie so 16, und da gab es so einen anderen Typen aus meiner Schule, der hat auch immer die anderen Hauptrollen gespielt, und das war so ein bisschen so mein Erzfeind irgendwie. Der hat auch immer die anderen Hauptrollen gespielt? Du hast immer die Hauptrollen gespielt. Es gab immer zwei Besetzungen sozusagen, und ich habe einen die Hauptrollen, und er die anderen Haupt Hauptrolle. Da entsteht automatisch so ein Konkurrenzverhältnis. Ich war mir ganz klar, ich bin der bessere Schauspieler als er, weil das war auch so ein bisschen so ein Schönling irgendwie, der total gut bei den Frauen ankam und ich halt überhaupt nicht so. Und deswegen war das in meiner Welt so, ich bin so das vergessene Genie, das noch keine Aufmerksamkeit kriegt und ihn lieben alle, weil er so gut aussieht, aber eigentlich bin ich der Bessere so. Und dann waren wir auf diesem Workshop und dann haben wir... Du warst früher schon sehr arrogant. Ja, natürlich, klar. Ich habe versucht, mir irgendwie die Welt so weisszureden, dass ich nicht komplett durchdrehe, aber meine eigenen fehlenden Selbstbewusstsein. Das ist meistens Arroganz. Das beschreibt Arroganz. Es ist letztendlich Arroganz, ja klar. Und dann wurden wir in so ein Zweipärchen eingeteilt und wir wurden eben zusammen als ein Zweipärchen eingeteilt und dann mussten wir noch kurz raus auf den Hof, während die anderen drinnen geprobt haben und die Pärchen mus mussten sich so verteilen und dann sind wir auf so eine Schaukel gegangen, er sass auf einer Schaukel, ich sass auf einer Schaukel und wir haben uns halt nicht offensichtlich gehasst, aber tief innen drin haben wir uns gehasst, aber oberflächlich haben wir halt so ein bisschen gesprochen, so ja irgendwie, keine Ahnung, ich war in dem Theaterstück und ja, ich weiß nicht, vielleicht gehe ich auf die Theaterschule und so, man hat sich halt komplett oberflächlich halt bebombt gegenseitig, gegenseitig, wer halt der Coolere ist. Und wir sitzen auf diesen Schaukeln und plötzlich, was passiert? Meine Schaukel reisst ab und ich falle auf den Boden, ohne dass wir geschaukelt sind. Also wir saßen nur auf den Schaukeln, aber ich erzähle so, ja auf jeden Fall, ich habe diesen Schauspiellehrer getroffen und mit dem habe ich jetzt auch irgendwie Präum... Und zack! Ich sitze auf dem Boden, augenweit aufgerissen und denke mir, fuck! Und er lacht sich kaputt. Und du hättest den Satz noch zu Ende sprechen müssen, ganz cool. Ja, er hat sich nichts passiert. Genau, der sagt, ich bin eigentlich ein ganz guter Typ. Aber er hat zumindest gelacht, was, glaube ich, in der Situation ganz okay war. Ja, das hielt total. Aber das war total, nein, eigentlich nicht, weil es war total sein Triumph. Er hat total triumphierend gelacht, er hat so richtig genossen, der ganze Hass für mich ist aus ihm rausgequollen und hat gelacht und ich konnte es auch gar nicht cool tragen, so, ja, ich weiß nicht, weil ich war halt schon irgendwie so eher der schöne, schlanke Typ und ich der hässliche, fette Typ und natürlich bei wem reisst die Schaukel, natürlich bei mir und so und tatsächlich mittlerweile ist er auch tatsächlich Schauspieler, wurde an der Otto-Falkenberg-Schaukelschule angenommen, ich nicht. er war wirklich der bessere Schauspieler und ist jetzt auch tatsächlich der krassere Typ geworden als ich. Deswegen, ich unterliege in allen Disziplinen tatsächlich, bin ich wesentlich... Macht er auch einen Podcast? Wir brauchen auch so einen Feindpot, einen Feindpot. Genau, Podcast-Feindschaft. Das wäre echt lustig, wenn wir eine Podcast-Feindschaft hätten. Wir würden in allen Situationen unterlegen sein und ich weiß nicht was... Aber wir würden trotzdem kämpfen, das ist unsere Schwächte. Ja, wir würden trotzdem kämpfen, am Ende würde unsere Schaukel trotzdem reißen wahrscheinlich. Ja, absolut. Oder einmal eine Situation, da war ich mit meiner Mutter in so einer Arztpraxis, in so einem Beredungsraum irgendwie und haben wir irgendwie Sachen gesprochen. Wir saßen auf solchen Stühlen, die so von der Seite so geschwungen aussehen, also so eine Lehne hinten und dann so ein Halbkreis, der am Boden endet. Und diese, sehr schwer zu beschreiben, glaube ich, aber diese Lehne hinten war nur so ein Streifen, also so ein Streifen, der ungefähr so auf Taillenhöhe den Körper stützt, aber darunter nicht so. Ich habe jetzt ein Bild von diesem Ding im Kopf, aber es ist kein Stuhl. Es sieht bislang eher so aus wie so eine Figur, die in so Kreisverkehren steht. Sowas in der Art stell dir sowas vor, aber da saßen wir auf jeden Fall drauf. Der Stuhlteil bestand aus zwei Lederstreifen, also ein dickerer Lederstreifen, auf den man sich draufgesetzt hat, und ein dünnerer Lederstreifen, gegen den man sich lehnen konnte. Aber sozusagen der Hosenbund ist unter dem Lederstreifen, an dem man sich lehnen kann. Da ist dann so ein Griss auf Eimer. Sicher, dass das ein Stuhl war, da liegt so ein hochkomplexes Untersuchungsgerät. So ein Gynäkologenstuhl, ja so, Herr Will, möchten Sie sich zu uns setzen? Okay, klar. Und auf jeden Fall, aber mir wird auch Herr Will angesprochen, wenn er vierzehn ist, auf jeden Fall war es dann so irgendwie beredend und so, ja, der Florentin ist ja körperlich sehr, sehr schlechter Verfassung und er muss auf jeden Fall weniger Sissigkeiten, also auch komplette Demütigung einfach von vorne bis hinten.
Und dann irgendwie war die Besprechung vorbei und alle stehen auf und ich war so ganz hinten auf dem Stuhl, so ganz nach hinten gerutscht und stehe auf und hebe tatsächlich mit meiner Hose, hebe ich unten an diese Lehe dran, hebe den gesamten Stuhl hoch, durch die Gleichgewichtsverlagerung schwingt der Stuhl nach hinten um, so unter meinem Hintern weg, und ich durch das plötzige Gewicht will mich wieder hinsetzen, will mich wieder auf den Stuhl setzen, der Stuhl war aber nach hinten geschwungen und ich falle einfach wieder auf den Boden. Also in meinen Augen war das der lustigste Anblick aller Zeiten, weil es wirklich so technisch war, wie das passiert ist.
Also wirklich, als hätte man es lange geprobt, ich hebe selbst meine Hose, heb den Stuhl hoch, schwingt ihn weg und lässt mich auf dem Boden. Ich würde dir jetzt auch gar nicht so viel Schuld geben, weil ich glaube, das ist einfach schuldvoll, die sind Designerstühlen. Die haben meistens, sind die Fallen eingebaut für Leute, die eigentlich nicht auf coolen Stühlen sitzen. Ja genau, die stoßen, die stoßen unkoolen Leute einfach ab. Genau, die Rache des Designers. Ja, ja, genau. Ich hätte mal so einen tiefen Tisch, so einen ganz tiefen Tisch, so einen Lounge-Tisch fürs Wohnzimmer. Und das sah ganz cool aus, aber es war einfach mega unpraktisch und der Tisch hat mich gehasst und der stosst einfach, das sind so Dinge, die sind total cool, aber die stoßen Leute wie uns ab. Ja, das stimmt. Manchmal ist man auch einfach nicht in der richtigen Situation. Das kann auch zu Scham führen, wenn man einfach in der falschen Umwelt ist. Man passt einfach nicht rein. Ja, genau. Es tut mir leid, aber wir müssen jetzt Schluss machen. Oh, okay. Aber ist nicht schlimm, wir haben ja fast eine Stunde geredet. Ja, vielen Dank, dass du da warst, Stefan Titzel. Vielen Dank für diese schamvolle Folge, mal einfach in die Scham hineingehört. Ja, danke, dass du auch direkt ins Thema geschaut. Ich habe jetzt erfahren, dass meine meine Eltern meine Eltern jetzt den Podcast hören. Ja, ist tatsächlich ein Problem. Vielleicht darüber nach vorne dran denken, bevor man irgendwann die Einbahnstrasse Richtung Pornos einschlägt. Ja, mir fallen einige Leute ein, die den Podcast hören. Na ja, gut. Vielleicht schneit das nochmal lieber raus. Schneiden, schneiden, schneiden. Und hör mal rein in die Stelle, wo du auf dem Klo warst. Einfach mal auf Scheiß. Ja, du schneidest das doch. Nee, ich bin da jetzt weg. Ja, ich kann auch nicht schneiden, ich habe auch keine Zeit. Du kannst es doch. Na gut, man muss jetzt nicht unbedingt mithören. Vielleicht sollen wir jetzt private Dinge einfach besprechen. Weitere Themenvorschläge und andere ist natürlich immer wieder gern gesehen auf Facebook, Twitter, Instagram, Pinterest und Tumblr. Und wer uns eine gute Bewertung bei iTunes gibt, kriegt ein von Florentin Will getragenes T-Shirt.